[Music]
hey what is the sky isn't pbht here and
I've shown you what's on my phone like
enough times now you've already seen it
this new series is dedicated to touring
other creative people's hugs and looking
at the tech behind how they do what they
do so this is episode 1 with tasty knife
set and his type of functional studio so
through the vlogs and various Casey
videos we've seen pretty much every
conceivable angle of his studio and it
can look like a mess like like chaos
actually there's a lot of surface area
covered there's stuff everywhere it
doesn't fit the traditional visual of a
neat or organized space but it is it
really is it's one of the most neat and
organized spaces even surprisingly so
let's walk through each of these
sections with caffeine it's this area
behind me this is like my tool workshop
construction area and the reason why I
have that is literally to maintain the
rest of the studio everything in here is
always breaking everything in here needs
to be built or rebuilt so it's nice
having my little tool shop back there to
do all that for those of you who have
seen cases videos which is probably most
of you you know that a lot of what he
does involves literally building stuff
like putting together new things that
are purpose-built for exact situations
or tasks and then once they're built you
can keep them around or use them again
if it comes up but this little tool area
a little corner here is where you'll
find the supplies to make that stuff all
this is exemplified by build over by if
you can't buy exactly what you need
build it this is the overhead shooting
rig so camera mounted here shooting
straight down I can see the image here
on the screen it makes it really easy
for animation but this table is just
like old busted up plywood and the
Missis plumbing pipe because to buy one
of these like a professional and super
expensive but like this does all the pro
stuff like it telescopes up and down
this moves back and forth so it's a
homemade overhead shooting rig so build
over by again I'm personally a huge fan
of
headshots obviously but there's no
denying it can take a lot of effort to
set them up just right and get them
looking the way you want every time
unless of course you build a permanent
rig to look exactly the way you want
every time and this rig is a lot more
nuanced than you might think there's a
2x4 with a Manfrotto baseplate screwed
into it so he can clip any camera with
the Manfrotto plate to it pretty quick
and there's an HDMI monitor on the other
side with a right angle cable that goes
directly into the camera plus a remote
trigger so he doesn't have to reach
around and press the record button on
whatever camera he's using there's a
measuring tape on the side of the 2x4 to
nail focus distance every time there's a
roll of white paper France and white
background a row of black paper for
instant black background there's an iPad
on an arm for keeping a shot list or
anything else really and these four
light bulbs in these circular diffusers
make it a super soft shadowless light
coming down onto the table their video
lights basically the majority of my
videos are shot on like portable cameras
little cameras like this but I keep this
big guy permanently set up here in the
office for like the formal talking to
camera footage this entire apparatus is
built to make it as easy as possible for
me to film myself because I typically
don't have someone here to help me
operate the camera so this big rig is
actually another of the same camera it's
a Sony a7r Mark to a 4k mirrorless
camera that I've actually used in the
past but of course it has a couple of
video making accessories so the camera
is in a cage made by tilta that
basically adds a bunch of quarter-twenty
screw holes a top handle and a pair of
rails to the front of the camera so the
rails on the front would be for
something like a motorized follow focus
to attach to the lens but Casey doesn't
use that he uses autofocus so instead he
uses the mounting holes in the cage for
adding things like a monitor arm and a
shotgun microphone for better audio and
then this whole cage and rails mounts to
the tripod directly so we can just move
that around the studio this set up plus
a single video light is pretty clutch
this is my desk this is where I work all
day every day I used to work in the back
I like sitting back there better but the
natural light on my face makes it a year
from to shoot videos sitting at this
desk this is like the laptop station
where I do the majority of my editing
and whatnot and then this is where I
want to do my
but this computer is just too slow to
edit on so I just use all of this for
data management 20 terabytes 20
terabytes 24 terabytes and then this is
60 terabytes
I never delete any footage so the
computer case you actually edits on
right now is the 2016 MacBook Pro 15
inch with touch bar despite all its
troubles and all its dongles it's the
most up to date machine Apple makes
right now and he and I are final cut
editors so that's a choice and then the
never deleting footage part as scary as
it sounds is actually true and I suspect
this storage collection will be growing
pretty soon but for now I count about a
hundred 50 terabytes of storage just at
the desk and the monitor setup is all
very specific as well so from top to
bottom its inside video surveillance
they're in hallway surveillance outside
studio surveillance from a GoPro that's
hanging out the window more outside
studio surveillance you know just in
case next door office surveillance and
another angle down the hallway and on
the bottom one and ultra-wide is the
only one actually hooked up to the Mac
Pro running a screensaver that just
plays The Godfather one and a godfather
to over and over on repeat so that's
where he spends a lot of the time and
that's where you could say the magic
happens and then around the corner is a
little nook around the back of the
studio which sports a vertical TV
connected to a vertical GoPro that's
always on this area not so functional
these are my dead drugs these have died
for various reasons like this one says
here crashed into Central Park pond
these things happen this is a charging
central for all of like my
point-and-shoot cameras and the idea
this is at a glance to be able to see
that everything is charging and ready to
go
a little secret about this though is
that most of these cameras I don't use
anymore so this is actually about to be
broken down and this wall is going to
repurposed it's such a beautiful picture
though I've been reluctant to actually
take them off the wall this area back
here this you should just be where I
kept all of my gear but it felt really
underutilized and I need to do like a
chill spot in the studio so I put this
couch in and this became like the gaming
station one thing that's super cool
underneath this couch we cut a big hole
and put the subwoofer there so when
you're playing call of duty like the
machine gun the sound it literally
shakes your ass because the base is so
strong okay
now I think this is a 65 inch TV it was
the cheapest TV I can get off of Amazon
looks fine Playstations not to the wall
going anything on the floor right here
and then up top here are my surveillance
monitors behind me is like all of the
gear all the camera equipment that I use
for making videos almost all of this is
is active and the idea with the layout
is to have it so I can grab and go as
quickly as possible this is the active
drone area this is a phantom 4 Pro
phantom 4 regular this is the Karma
Mavic battery charging station
propellers these are my cameras these
are the cameras that all work they're
fully operational batteries are charged
ready to go even these older ones I
still keep at the ready just because I
have them GoPro set up over here SLRs
point shoots lenses a little known
secret of my studio here is that I
really take advantage of the space under
the floor so this trap door here this is
like bounce boards lighting equipment
c-stands and some more like weirdo
esoteric gear like body mounts cool
stuff I don't use it often it's like
keeping the floor so the Casey Neistat
studio is low-key kinda a masterpiece
it's a tightly woven collection of
Technology and video tools and
construction tools that make it possible
and maybe the most functional use of the
square footage imaginable and it all
comes back to two main things build over
by and being a lot more organized than
it actually looks it's not traditional
and even just being there for the first
time and me looking around as a video
person and as a tech head and a bit of a
perfectionist sometimes myself you
notice a couple things number one pretty
much everything is labeled like
meticulously did you notice that like
boxes of things categories of gear
supplies tools equipment tech stuff it's
all literally hand labelled so ideally
you can find exactly what you need in
second and the number to almost every
wire instead of being invisible or
shoved behind a desk like we typically
do it it's strung out and visible and
pinned up against the wall so you can
trace everything to where it's
then it's a different type of
organization then maybe we're used to in
a normal super clean studio and then
number three the studio is exceptionally
well lit I mean it is a video studio
after all but everywhere you look
there's lights ceiling lights dome
lights diffusion satellites all things
to brighten the space to give it a
consistent even look and to give a
subtle blown out bokeh when you're
shooting video and to make it feel even
bigger than it actually is everything is
well lit all of them have purpose and
place and it seems like every square
inch of space every surface is used for
something and that's what you can do
when you've been in a space for a decade
so that's been it thanks for watching
hopefully you now have a better
appreciation of the space you've
probably seen in so many videos so
thanks to Casey for the walkthrough
definitely subscribe to his channel for
more awesome videos all the time and
I'll catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]